we broke the law in 13 states and 93
counties our moving average was 100
point 3 miles an hour I was a criminal
the cannibal bakers sea to shining sea
Memorial Trophy - was started by Brock
aids from Car and Driver magazine
generally it was run from the red ball
parking garage in Manhattan to the
Portofino in Redondo Beach one of the
drivers from cannonball named Richard
Guardi started an event called the u.s.
express the total ops 2813 miles leave
out of New York through the Lincoln
Tunnel into New Jersey and in
Pennsylvania through West Virginia for
just a few miles than Ohio Indiana
Illinois Missouri Oklahoma Texas New
Mexico Arizona and upon the fastest time
was 32 dollars and 7 minutes by David GM
and Doug Turner in a brewery three away
and so that kind of became the mark to
beat until 2006 a team of Alex Roy and
Dave Maher and Corey wells set out the
BMW m5 from the New York classic car
club in Manhattan and arrived 31 hours
and four minutes later and established a
new transcontinental record it was that
idea that really had inspired me
qualified people and well-prepared cars
could do something well beyond
of our government and ours was not the
same anteed establishment idea but it
does translate and it was something that
you know was endlessly inspiring to me
we used a car that was nine years old at
the time and then we set about equipping
it for this kind of a trip so we had
three navigation systems three radar
detectors two laser jammer systems two
additional fuel tanks with transfer
Thompson gauges panel tilt switches to
control everything a CB radio with
antenna police scanner an antenna a
third-party tracking device the
ambulance traffic light changes that a
friend of mine had rigged up it was
probably just shy of 50 thousand dollars
I mean this was as much of a shoestring
budget as anyone had ever approached
this with I think of this all as a big
equation there was really nothing that
made it seem like this was even possible
it's not something that you do by
yourself it's not something that you can
do by yourself
this is a team endeavor we had five
different Scouts different parts of the
route and they would run 150 to 200
miles ahead of us they would radio back
or just call us on a cell phone and tell
us where there was construction where
there were you know accidents or cars
pulled over in the side of the road kind
of our own little network like waves our
moving average was 100 point three miles
an hour we stopped three times for gas
and about halfway through each tank we
would stop to switch drivers Dave is
taking a leak outside of my window we
passed about five fixed speed traps and
probably a dozen cops moving in either
direction but we had no tickets
generally anything over a hundred or
anything more than thirty miles an hour
in excess so the speed limit is going to
be considered reckless driving and that
can be anywhere from 180 days to a year
in jail so there were a lot of possible
negative consequences the fatigue was so
great that as we entered the LA basin I
said guys we're going to break the
record we're going to bring 30 hours
which everyone thought was the wall I
said we can break 29 if we push like
crazy but I need both of you to be as on
alert as we were a day ago and if you're
up for it we'll push it and we voted we
went fast
I needed them to be on alert and I
needed them to understand that we're not
out of the woods yet and just because
the signs say la were not done right
there
finally get there you navigate through
Redondo Beach and you pull into the
parking lot at the Portofino end and I
remember stopping the stop watches and
taking pictures of the nav screens and
just reading it and it said twenty-eight
hours and 50 minutes and it was so far
outside of my comprehension and it was
terrifying because I knew what the
burden of proof was and we weren't
claiming something that was within the
imagination of the rest of this
underworld that might care about the
idea we were saying that we crushed it
and that idea had me checking everything
doing all the math over and over again
logging on and look at the GPS tracking
just make sure it was all actually there
because none of it made any sense you
just assumed that there was some
miscalculation but you watched on that
stopwatch stuck to the dashboard every
second tick on it was surreal
I remember the standing on the pier at
the Portofino staring out at the sea if
it exists thinking
and that moment of recognition that
something I chased for the better part
of 10 years and it invested everything I
was capable of putting into it had paid
off and if I literally had never gotten
another moment out of it than that I've
been just as happy I hold the record for
the Cannonball Run drive from New York
to Los Angeles I did it in 28 hours and
50 minutes